want to bring you a bit of breaking news  regarding that whale that was stranded  in the thames and sad news i'm afraid  it's been  put down by vets that young minky whale  it became stranded  in the thames on sunday well a vet has  euthanized  the animal it was seen in a very  distressed state  trapped against the riverbank near  teddington  in south west london now you may  remember rescuers had previously  tried to urge it to go back up the river  back  out to the estuary but they did say it  was unlikely  the animal which is uh 10  around about 10 foot long would survive  and  indeed it clearly was in such a  distressed state the kindest thing was  to  to euthanase it and it has now died